en China avanzan las protestas contra la
política de cero covid la ONU pide a las
autoridades que respeten el derecho a la
manifestación pacífica mientras el
Ministerio de exteriores del gigante
asiático asegura no estar informado de
las movilizaciones
el sistema eléctrico en Ucrania estaría
restablecido en gran parte del
territorio según las autoridades tras la
reciente oleada de bombardeo rusos sin
embargo el presidente vuelo
dimirselensky advirtió que Rusia estaba
planeando nuevos ataques e instó a los
ciudadanos a estar preparados para
soportar días sin electricidad
en Italia tras el deslizamiento de
tierra del sábado en la isla de isque ha
causado por las Fuertes lluvias los
equipos de rescate buscan a cuatro
personas desaparecidas mientras el
número de víctimas mortales se eleva a 8
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta nueva edición informativa
en China porque este fin de semana en
ciudades como Beijing o Shangai tuvieron
lugar Las mayores protestas en años
decenas de personas manifestaron contra
la política de Cero covid en
movilizaciones que han continuado este
lunes en Hong Kong la policía detuvo a
un número desconocido de participantes
en esta inédita contestación que estalló
a raíz de la muerte de 10 personas este
jueves en un incendio en yang del que
supuestamente no pudieron escapar debido
a los confinamientos en las marchas de
este fin de semana Se oyeron consignas
que van desde demandas de más libertad
de expresión hasta la renuncia del
presidente Chip y un grito unánime el
fin de la restricciones que empezaron
hace casi tres años lluis Muñoz con las
reacciones internacionales
extrañas protestas contra los
confinamientos en Beijing
Shanghai
[Aplausos]
o Hong Kong esto en China mientras en el
mundo las manifestaciones se extienden
al frente de las embajadas como en
Londres capital de Reino Unido y Tokio
capital de Japón pero más allá del
malestar los efectos son notables los
principales índices de Wall Street
abrieron a la baja el lunes y la
comunidad internacional empieza a
pronunciarse al respecto así habló el
canciller de Reino Unido bueno las
protestas contra el gobierno chino son
raras y cuando suceden creo que el mundo
debería Tomar nota pero sobre todo es el
gobierno chino el que debería Tomar nota
de forma similar se expresó el gobierno
alemán
hemos tomado nota de las noticias de
protestas en varias de las principales
ciudades chinas también de los informes
de acciones a veces violentas de las
fuerzas de seguridad contra los
manifestantes sobre el terreno
puedo decirles que por supuesto nuestra
embajada en Beijing así como nuestras
otras misiones diplomáticas en China
continúan observando la situación de
cerca la pasada semana a un incendio en
un edificio de urumkie capital de
shinyang causó 10 muertos los
manifestantes argumentaron que las
graves restricciones que impidieron a
los fallecidos escapar y su rechazo se
ha convertido en un clamor cada vez
mayor contra casi tres años de
confinamientos aún así el país continúa
con su política de cero covid
vamos ahora con noticias de la guerra en
Ucrania las autoridades ucranianas han
restablecido el suministro energético en
gran parte del país tras los ataques
rusos de esta semana en regiones como
jerson los ciudadanos vuelven a tener
acceso al gas y a la electricidad Eso sí
en medio de la devastación causada por
los bombardeos y las advertencias de que
los ataques rusos podrían repetirse Alba
Santana nos amplía
tras día sin gas ni electricidad
eliudmila antonenco y su hijo Alexander
vuelven a tener acceso a estos servicios
en su casa de gerson tenemos gas tenemos
electricidad Ojalá tuviéramos agua
también para usar el baño adecuadamente
el 24 de noviembre una bomba
supuestamente rusa cayó sobre su casa
las ventanas saltaron por los aires y
una de las paredes colapsó ahora a pesar
de que la casa está en ruinas madre e
hijo siguen aquí porque no tienen otro
sitio donde ir
la ventana se llenó de luz todo se
iluminó luego hubo muchas explosiones
estábamos muy asustados Me alegro de que
Alexander siga aquí si hubiera caído
Entre 10 y 30 centímetros más hacia aquí
yo no estaría aquí pero tengo 82 años no
es para tanto
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte como
Lilia krishenko que perdió a sus dos
padres en ese mismo ataque
nunca había mucho polvo no podía ver
nada mi hijo y yo nos escondimos en el
baño hoy a mi padre gritar diciéndome
que llamar a una ambulancia porque mi
madre estaba herida pero no había
conexión
a pesar de que el gas y la electricidad
en los dos servicios más importantes de
cara al infierno se han restablecido los
ciudadanos de gerson no tienen acceso al
agua ni a otras redes como la de la
televisión además el presidente bolo de
mercelenski ha advertido a los
ucranianos que todavía no están a salvo
sabemos que los terroristas están
planeando nuevos ataques lo sabemos con
certeza y mientras tengan misiles
desafortunadamente no se calmarán
una situación complicada de cara al
invierno cada vez más cerca y para el
que los ucranianos sumidos en la guerra
no están preparados
y en la previa de la reunión de
ministros de relaciones exteriores de la
otan en bucarest que empezará mañana el
secretario general de la organización
jeans toltenberg se pronunció sobre los
ataques rusos a la red eléctrica de
Ucrania aseguró que el presidente ruso
of Vladimir Putin Está tratando de usar
el invierno como arma de guerra por otro
lado stoltenberg declaró que espera que
en la reunión se aborde de forma central
la necesidad de ayudar a Ucrania con sus
sistemas de defensa antiaérea escuchemos
el presidente Putin ahora está tratando
de usar el invierno como arma de guerra
contra Ucrania y esto es horrible
debemos estar preparados para más
ataques esa es la razón por la cual los
aliados de la otan han aumentado su
apoyo a Ucrania
y vamos a Londres la primera dama de
Ucrania olenas de lenska se reunió con
ascatamurti la esposa del Primer
Ministro británico en el número 10 de
downstrid la primera dama de Ucrania se
encuentra en la capital británica para
participar en una conferencia
internacional sobre cómo abordar la
violencia sexual Durante los conflictos
armados murtis saludó as del enska con
un abrazo y le dio la bienvenida al
interior del edificio luego las dos
mujeres colgaron adornos en un árbol de
navidad frente a la famosa puerta
principal mientras el enski no has
abandonado Ucrania desde el inicio de la
guerra selenska es la encargada de los
viajes diplomáticos viajó a Estados
Unidos y participó ante el congreso y
asistió también en Londres al funeral de
la Reina Isabel II
y en Italia continúan las tareas de
rescate tras el violento deslizamiento
de tierra en la turística isla de isquia
de este sábado pasado los equipos de
emergencia buscan a cuatro desaparecidos
mientras se elevó a 8 el número de
víctimas mortales entre ellas se cuenta
un recién nacido expertos y activistas
aseguran que la construcción de
edificios ilegales aumentó los riesgos
de desastres naturales en esta zona
insular próxima al mar de la ciudad de
Nápoles más detalles en el siguiente
informe
como si la colina se rompiera en pedazos
en pocas horas el lodo se adentró
cientos de metros en el mar Arrasando
todo a su paso Los buzos estuvieron
peinando las aguas de la costa italiana
de isquia con la ayuda de helicópteros
aquí es donde se encontró la primera
víctima una mujer de 31 años que
trabajaba en una tienda local hallada
muerta a cientos de metros de su casa
los bomberos están turnando para buscar
en la zona tratando de encontrar a los
desaparecidos pero la tarea sigue siendo
difícil en paralelo el gobierno decretó
el estado de emergencia lo que hace que
sea complejo es que nos encontramos bajo
la zona debilitada por el
desprendimiento las casas están llenas
de barro por lo que es muy complicado
Acceder al interior y continuar nuestra
búsqueda
alrededor de 200 personas fueron
desalojadas algunas se refugiaron en
este hotel cerca del puerto esta mujer
refugiada con su hijo y su nieta se
enteró de que su cuñada fue encontrada
muerta bajo los escombros
estamos tristes mantuve la esperanza
hasta el final otra tragedia en esta
ciudad y en esta familia no sé cómo voy
a afrontar los próximos días
[Música]
esta familia Tuvo más suerte su casa
sigue en pie a pocos metros de la
trayectoria de la luz
ves nuestra casa aquí pasó por allí y es
que ya recibió casi 13 centímetros de
lluvia en seis horas la mayor
precipitación en 20 años Este alud es el
tercer desastre natural que golpea la
isla ya víctima de un terremoto en 2017
y de mortales inundaciones en 2019
una operación conjunta entre varios
países europeos y emiratos árabes Unidos
ha desmantelado un mega Cártel de la
droga el grupo era responsable de un
tercio del tráfico de cocaína en Europa
la europol que ha coordinado la
operación celebró este tipo de
colaboración internacional Marina
Colorado nuestra corresponsal en Madrid
nos amplía la información
dos años de investigación y 12 días de
redadas conjuntas y simultáneas en
varios países europeos y en emiratos
árabes Unidos han terminado con la
detención de 49 personas vinculadas a un
megacartel de droga que movía un tercio
del mercado de la cocaína en Europa esta
trama que podría perfectamente ser el
guión de una película de ficción forma
parte de una operación policial
internacional apodada luz del desierto
coordinada por europol la policía
europea entre los 49 detenidos están los
6 líderes de este megacartel que
dirigían el tráfico desde Dubai
conocidos Como los de la droga en la
operación en la que participaron España
Países Bajos Francia Bélgica y emiratos
árabes Unidos se incautaron además 33
toneladas de cocaína y se desmanteló la
infraestructura logística en varios
puertos de Europa por donde entraban las
drogas desde latinoamérica en España
donde el pasado 8 de noviembre fueron
detenidas 13 personas la operación
inició en marzo de 2020 con la
incautación de un contenedor con casi
700 kilos de cocaína en Valencia al este
del país Pese a que en ese entonces no
hubo detenciones se identificó a Panamá
como el país en el que se introdujo la
droga en ese contenedor según datos de
la ONU la mitad de los 20 países que más
consumen cocaína del mundo son europeos
y según el observatorio europeo de
drogas y toxicomanías España es el país
europeo con más prevalencia de consumo
de esta droga con el 11,2% de la
población entre los 15 y los 64 años
afirmando que consume cocaína
las autoridades de Irlanda imponen a
Facebook una multa de 277 millones de
dólares por una gran fuga de datos
personales que se encontraban
disponibles online se trata de la cuarta
sanción de dublín contra el gigante
tecnológico en septiembre el regulador
Irlandés puso otra multa de 400 a 5
millones de euros a Instagram en total
en Irlanda la empresa matriz meta está
penalizada con cerca de mil millones de
euros mientras los reguladores
irlandeses investigan otros 13 casos
contra el grupo de Mark Zuckerberg
recordemos que el comisionado Irlandés
de protección de datos es el principal
regulador de las grandes tecnológicas en
la Unión Europea dado que las empresas
del bictech como Apple Google tiktok o
meta ubican sus sedes en ese país por su
laxa política fiscal
y cerramos en Qatar donde la Copa del
Mundo de fútbol está en pleno apogeo se
espera que entre Unidos millones de
aficionados extranjeros visiten el país
antes de la final del 18 de diciembre
Mientras tanto un número similar de
extranjeros vive ahí representan el 90%
de la población total su trabajo bajo
condiciones a de explotación moderna ha
permitido que el país construyera la
infraestructura del mundial en un tiempo
récord y sin embargo no pueden asistir a
los partidos veamos
un ambiente festivo en este terremoto
estadio de doja transformado en un infan
son durante el torneo mundialista un
espacio reservado las trabajadores
inmigrantes de Qatar que constituyen el
90% de su población de India bangladesh
en nepal sri lanka y Pakistán ganan un
máximo de 250 euros al mes en suficiente
para poder permitirse una entrada para
ver los partidos que ronda entre los 60
y los 200 euros esta primera etapa de la
competición
toda la gente Está disfrutando aquí pero
yo no tengo ninguna posibilidad ninguna
posibilidad de entrar en el estadio solo
vengo aquí solo puedo disfrutar bueno
entre los 15.000 que acudieron a la zona
de aficionados esta tarde muchos
vinieron a apoyar a Argentina y a su
delantero estrella Lionel Messi
una breve oportunidad para desahogarse
entre largos nocturnos
[Música]
tengo trabajo durante 14 horas y llegó
una hora tarde Así que tengo que ir
rápido a trabajar
pero estoy contento ya está han ganado
he ganado estoy contento puedo trabajar
14 horas sí
Qatar dice que ha mejorado las
condiciones laborales de sus
trabajadores migrantes Pero según varias
ongs el maltrato sigue siendo una
práctica habitual en febrero una
investigación del diario británico de
Garden reveló que 6.500 migrantes había
muerto en las obras de construcción
cataríes en el país se han construido
siete estadios tres líneas de metro y un
aeropuerto en un tiempo
récord para [__] el mundial más caro de
la historia
sigan con nosotros
[Música]